nearly 30 years after candyman first
haunted moviegoers in theaters the
hook-handed menace is back and what is
being described as a spiritual sequel
from oscar-winning get out writer jordan
peel and director nia de costa here are
the biggest unanswered questions the new
candyman may leave you with
first some backstory in the 1992 film
directed by bernard rose and written by
rose and horror maestro clyde parker
chicago grad student helen lyle summons
the vengeful spirit candyman back to
existence while researching a thesis on
urban legends this spirit is daniel
robitaille the 19th century son of a
slave who became a successful artist
commissioned by wealthy white families
to paint their portraits however when
daniel fathered a child with the
daughter of one of those families he was
gravely injured by a lynch mob who
smeared him with honeycomb attracting a
swarm of bees that stung him to death
the 2021 version of candyman examines
the same tale but with some new twists
it begins in the early 1970s in the
cabrini green housing projects the same
area where the terror and the original
tale took place now however the
neighborhood is all but non-existent
because cabrini green has been
gentrified candyman is no longer daniel
but sherman fields a hook-handed man who
hands out candy to children in the
neighborhood sherman is murdered in an
altercation with police during an
encounter with a young boy named billy
burke in an apartment building laundry
room the adult billy who now goes by
william recounts a legend to artist
anthony mccoy who uses it as his
inspiration for an exhibition at the art
gallery where his girlfriend brianna
cartwright is the director the
exhibition tells the tragic tale of
candyman and how he can be summoned by
people who look in the mirror and say
his name five times while fans of the
original film know the deadly outcome of
such actions the new candyman might
leave you with a fresh set of unanswered
questions some that actually have clear
answers there's not so much
since helen died in the original
candyman movie it's completely sensible
that her character might be brought back
in flashback scenes in the new version
which is technically a sequel so where
is she instead of using footage from the
original film or digitally de-aging
virginia madsen to retell helen's story
nia de costa and jordan peel creatively
bring her back in different forms
instead of conventional flashback scenes
helen's tale is first told through
shadow puppetry which decosta said at a
press event for candyman presented her a
creative option not to rely on flashback
scenes for the most part the director
said she wanted this movie to stand on
its own and not to rely too explicitly
on the original movie from there she
said it just sort of became really less
about flashbacks and more about how we
depict people telling these stories how
would depict these legends and also we'd
pick these moments of violence
throughout history madsen does
eventually appear in the film very
briefly when anthony sees an old image
of her in a newspaper report detailing
how she was implicated in murders in the
cabrini green neighborhood madsen's
voice is also heard in tapes that
anthony gains access to in a library in
a curious casting move there's a tough
highbrow art critic assessing anthony's
exhibit finley stevens who resembles a
young madsen decosta said at the
candyman press event that spence's
resemblance to the original film star
was by mere happenstance and not design
surrender to me now
candyman wouldn't be the same without
tony todd's involvement in the film in
some capacity and yes he does turn up in
the film in a very meaningful cameo
appearance but what role does he play
since candyman 2021 is a creation
combining old and new ideas peel and
acosta went a different direction when
it came to working in a major theme in
the film that was clearly inspired by
the current climate and social justice
movements instead of todd's daniel
robitaille being featured throughout the
film he is referenced to by the adult
bobby as one of several to have suffered
the same sort of racial injustice that
befell sherman fields the iteration of
the candyman featured most prominently
in this new version that's not to say
however that fields is the only version
of candyman who appears in the new
iteration of the tale
anthony develops burn-like lesions on
his right hand after the ghost of
candyman materializes and kills his
first two victims news outlets naturally
detail the horrific incident and a
reporter on the scene divulges to her
audience a title of the exhibit say my
name the reporter also refers to the
painter as rising star anthony mccoy
much to the surprise of the artist who
is watching coverage on television at
that point in the film it appears
anthony is consumed by the newfound fame
the tragedy has brought him even though
the murders are responsible for it after
the reports he says almost giddily say
my name as a way to embrace his
notoriety so why does anthony obsess
over his candyman exhibit longing for
more fame is morbid curiosity in the
candyman legend deepens and he begins to
do more research and while anthony
suffers horrific hallucinations as a
result his obsession continues to
inspire more images as he parlays his
initial creation into a larger exhibit i
feel really connected to this story
one anthony doesn't realize is that he
has fallen under the spell of the
candyman curse and is somehow tied to a
tragic event involving the spirit
decades prior which is fully revealed
later in the film at that point though
anthony has entered the point of no
return his fate is sealed
no there isn't anything wrong with the
projection so what's with the reversed
logos the backwards logos for universal
pictures mgm braun and monkey paw
productions at the beginning of the film
were done on purpose presumably in an
homage to candyman lore after all the
spirit of a candyman doesn't materialize
in physical form only in a reflection in
the mirror the studio and peel are
clearly making a visual reference to the
legend by showing their logos backwards
much like a reflection in a mirror not
surprisingly mirrors appear everywhere
in candyman they are at anthony's
exhibit which is the location where
candyman kills his first two victims and
an elevator anthony takes in the
libraries made up entirely of mirrors
brianna attempts fade by standing in
front of a mirror yet doesn't give in to
her impulses but a group of high school
girls laugh off the legend and say
candyman's name five times and pay
dearly for it
as fans well know by now saying
candyman's name five times in a mirror
is what's needed to summon the violent
spirit however in the age of the social
justice movement in the u.s over the
past few years following the high
profile deaths of black people across
the country during altercations with
police certain phrases now have greater
meaning so what's the significance of
say my name calling on people to say the
names of the dead has become a prominent
part to the public conversation in
recent years and throughout the making
of the film the thing that i always came
back to is the truth of the pain that
was at the center of the story of
candyman in this way say my name serves
a dual purpose it's the title of
anthony's exhibit daring patrons of his
work to say candyman five times to find
out if the legend is indeed real and an
artful play on the real life phrases
used to call attention to and
memorialize the dead
with a bloody third act that leads to
the transformation of a key character
into the new candyman peel and acosta
have left the door wide open for more
candyman films but will we get them
naturally the production of a sequel for
any film is dependent on the box office
success of its predecessor so the new
candyman will have to be a big enough
hit with moviegoers at the box office
and on home video to justify universal
and mgm's investment in a sequel the
good news for peel and acosta is that
candy man was made for around 25 million
dollars a relatively small amount by
modern standards even with the covet 19
pandemic still wreaking havoc on box
office returns the new candyman
shouldn't have much trouble making its
money back as the 1992 version of
candyman demonstrated there is more room
for additional tales about the character
should peel and acosta wish to move in
that direction the original film spawned
two sequels candyman farewell to the
flesh in 1995 and candyman day of the
dead in 1999 will this new imagining
return for further stories we'll just
have to say the name and see
[Music]
don't say that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]